josh is with us in Indianapolis Josh
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show better
than I deserve sir how can I help
I'm calling today about my sister she's
going through a divorce right now and
she's in a really big phone from that
she went $11 an hour and she says about
her dollars a month for rent and she has
tens of thousands of dollars of student
loans off she has no hope and she turns
him one of those possibilities out for
preachers together some hope on the
video in two days I'm wondering where I
can do the house to help her laughing
yeah
how old is she 31 okay I'm having
trouble hearing you your phone's going
all over the place make sure you're
speaking directly into it please okay so
she's 31 and if she have children hmm
yeah she has a four-year-old boy and
we're in this okay where are your
parents you know where are they they
live here in Indiana with close to me
and she lives in Boise oh she lives in
Boise okay yeah all right well there's a
proper doctrine from Scripture that
would result in something that sounds
like what st. Ambrose used to say we
pray like it all depends on God we
worked like it all depends on us mm-hmm
and so sometimes folks who are in a
desperate situation and I've been there
you right around the time I get
desperate is when I get stupid and
sometimes I can get sucked into a bad
doctrine situation that causes me to
wait on God to fix my life and he's up
there a loving Heavenly Father saying a
child I want you to learn some lessons
from this process and those lessons will
fix your life
and you know like when I'm teaching my
baby to ride a bicycle I let go of the
seat and then and then if they go crazy
and try to jump occur but they you know
they may have to learn a lesson in that
process that doesn't mean I'm not a
Leavitt loving Heavenly Father because I
watched them fall over off that bike
though and sometimes I've gone through
that where I know that God was just
letting go of the seat and letting me
let him and suffer the consequences of
my stupid choices and it's painful but
it's a loving act by a loving father and
it does not match up with a prosperity
gospel and so you know that's why it's
always hilarious to me when people say
Hill Ramsey's prosperity gospel crap I
don't have enough hair to be the
prosperity gospel so um but the so you
know I think the way you can help her is
help her have some real clear next steps
because she's scared she's got a baby
she's broke she's hurting and that makes
her vulnerable and so anything we can do
to help her with her career she's got a
hundred thousand dollars of student loan
debt I don't know how much longer she
has I just said tens of thousands tens
of thousands okay did she did she get
her degree yeah she has a master's
degree and something related the Bible
I'm not sure what it is it's not like
there's anything really useful like that
okay
a master's degree in Bible could be very
useful depending on what she's going to
do for a living there are lots of Bible
teachers in Bible colleges that make a
whole lot more than $11 an hour with a
master's degree in Bible so it can be
very useful career move not to mention
being very spiritually fulfilling and so
her spiritual walk means a lot to her is
what we're saying she has invested a lot
of time a lot of money and a lot of her
life in in her spiritual walk which is
awesome and now we've just got to figure
out a way to help her do that not at
Alette
dollars an hour and so what what fits
into her passions as Ken Coleman says
and into her training he calls that the
sweet spot when your passion meets your
training and she's got passion and
training for this for the subject area
that we're talking about and then so now
I just gotta figure out way to help her
build a career in that area without
being vulnerable to somebody trying to
share the Sheep here or fleece the Sheep
as we say and so I don't know if that's
what's happening but the way you frame
the question that's what you think is
happening well no and so yeah the the
student loan debt is the least of her
trouble right now getting her career
going and her broken heart mending and
emotionally squaring her shoulders and
feeling strong again after all she's
been through which is going to be
involved making more money and putting
some distance between her and this
divorce and that's the best way you can
help her is just love her through that
process and if you can coach her along
the career side and then the money you
know we can knock out ten thousand
dollars in debt once we solve a broken
heart in $11 an hour but those two
things are going to hinder the ability
to get to to get to the tens of
thousands of dollars of student loan
debt so yeah she's gonna have to work
like it all depends on her pray like it
all depends on God work like it all
depends on her work a plan work a system
work hard make money be tired be
fatigued because you work all the time
because work is where money comes from
and that's in the Bible by the way the
diligent prosper that's in Scripture
those that don't work don't eat Paul
said that's pretty harsh but it's in
there I told my kids that help them when
they were teenagers because teenagers
like to eat don't work don't eat it's in
the Bible you know so I mean you can you
can have these common sense applications
of Scripture when you're in the ditch
and and it's not unspiritual but it and
it's not
self-help dressed as Jesus it's it's
it's a doctrine straight out of
Scripture that God chooses to bless us
and he most often chooses to bless us as
a part of our hard work he very seldom
calls this week to grow in a farmer's
field unless the farmer plants it he
causes the ring God does he causes the
Sun God does but all of that just brings
mud in the field if the farmer doesn't
plant the wheat so we both get to play a
part in this work like it all depends on
you pray like it all depends on God
farmers know about prayer they believe
in it and they know about the
capriciousness of toxic theologies yeah
you don't get to tell god what to do he
kind of thinks he's God and so that's
how this works it's a fun thing we get
to walk in this with this walk of faith